Hey, how are you doing? I've been gone
for a while. I know. And I apologize for
that. I know there are dozens of you out
there waiting for my content. And today
I bring you something very different. A
gameplay video, but all by myself. Yes,
there's no need for friends. And I never
lose. Actually, I can lose because I'm
trying to make it so that there's kind
of one main character each series. In
today's episode, we have Flubs. Yes, the
legendary idiot that does deliver
excellent payoff, but also shoots itself
in the foot every chance it gets. And
since we're messing with ourselves, we
got to mess with our opponents, too,
right? So, we have over 35 copies of
removals in the deck. And we hope to
disrupt everyone while we build up some
advantage and eventually take over the
game with these storm payoff cards. And
today, we're going to test the deck
against your average table. I'm trying
to simulate what the average pot would
look like at your local game store.
Starting with the oldie but goody Kalia
ranked at number five despite being more
than a decade old. Holding strong here
is your typical Kalia deck. Big angels,
demons, and dragons. Nothing special,
but it's always a blast to play and
apply some early pressure to the table.
And following that, we have Bellow at
rank 34. One of the most popular new
commanders from the past couple years,
giving a new twist to the Enchantress
build. But we are doing something a
little bit different. We are going for
artifacts. I don't think it's quite as
good as the enchantment version, but it
can be really explosive with the amount
of ramp and arguably is more resilient
with better protection and recursion.
And our third opponent is a lateg game
deck with not the most popular
commander, but an archetype you'd
commonly see in groups. Mill the master
aims to mill our opponents while
stealing from their graveyards. This
deck isn't your typical simic value
build, but it does become more powerful
as it survives to the late game. more
about this format after the game, but if
you have any suggestions, please let me
know in the comments. So, with no
further ado, let's begin our game.
Playing with myself cuz friends are
overrated. Okay, let's begin. So, let's
pick our first player um with our app
here. Looks like we're starting. Okay,
starting with flips. So, let's do that.
Draw our opening hand. Take a look at
what we can get. Oo, land. Land.
Sorcerers class. Land. Land.
Okay.
Okay. Wait, that's seven cards. Seven
cards, five lens. Honestly, I think this
is pretty good. And when I cast
sorcerers class, I'll probably keep more
lands. Yeah, depending on what I what we
draw next. Um, ideally, we want
something like exploration or a zusa.
But yeah, usually with fluffs, you're
pretty like you're free to keep whatever
really as long as you have lands. Yeah,
I mean, in theory, seven lands is pretty
good. Yeah, because you're eventually
dumping your hand and all those lands
will be played. And once you play them,
you are set for for the next few turns.
So, we will keep this. Yeah, no
complaints here. Next up, let's take a
look at Bellow.
Okay, Cyberman. That was test. Okay,
this is not looking good. No, not no not
enough lands. Too many big mana
artifacts. That's the problem with
Bellow. Yeah, we early game we don't
have enough ramp or setup and
uh we we it will be really slow by the
time we cast these. So will be like turn
turn turn turn turn turn turn turn turn
turn turn turn turn seven seven seven
turn turn turn turn turn eight eight no
nope okay mulligan
draw
three lands protection spell okay this
is good this is good um not ideal
because we don't have like a four or
five drop uh artifact but having you
know having the talisman here having a
protection spell it's good and war room
nice yeah I think this is fine I
Hopefully we draw well, but um yeah,
this is an average start for Val. If we
don't get there, if this happens too
often, then we should look to adjust the
deck a little bit. But right now, let's
we'll try it. We're just testing. Okay,
now the master draw.
This looks good. Yes, this looks good.
One more. Yo, this is perfect. Yeah, I
mean ideally we want a two drop ramp,
but having this and this is nice. We are
really well set up for the early game.
And wait, is this the one? No, this is
the recursion spell. Yes. So, not as
good. I was hoping for the two drop
ramp. What's it called? I forgot. But
there is a manador MDFC. So, this is
fine. Let's keep it. And Calia.
Okay, this looks amazing already. Yeah.
Um, Arena Signit. We just need one
demon, one angel that can draw us cards
like a big bomb. We can farewell. Okay.
Oh, just give me give me ah no,
you don't have the demon.
But I mean, black market is fine.
Although turn three, we should be
caliing with haste. But either way, we
are not complaining. It's just we're
not, you know, we don't have a perfect
start, but this is pretty close to as
good as it can get in terms of resource.
Yeah, we have card draw, we have ramp,
and we have a farewell. So, let's keep
this. Okay, moving on to turn one with
flubs. Let's draw another land. Why not?
Let's start with are we going to cycle
this? Probably not. So, let's Yeah,
we're not spending three mana to cycle
this. So, let's play it. Pass. Draw.
Okay. Echoes of eternity. Um, play a
land. Pass the master. Draw. Factor
fiction. Seems good. Let's play a tap
land and pass the turn. Talia. Oh, we
got the speed demon. That's awesome. Oh,
that's good. That's good. But let's not
play the arena just yet. Let's use our
fetchland to get a trieland so that this
enters untapped and our mana is fixed.
Okay, pay one life.
Here's the triand
flops on top. Draw another land. I think
this is where we uh I think we can do a
sorcerer class. We'll try to dig for a
extra land card, but if we don't get it,
we'll see what we get. Um, let's do
that. Draw two.
Yeah, we might. Uh, honestly, do we need
a wear and tear on this board? No.
Soaring.
I don't think we're going to wear and
tear. We're just going to flubs and try
to play as many lands as possible. So,
let's dump the wear and tear and dump
this land, I guess. Not very useful.
Volcanic Fissure. Um, and pass on top.
Bellow draw another land. Not Not ideal
here. Um, let's play uh War Room, I
guess. Play War Room. play a signate you
we really need to top deck a four drop
artifact five drop I'll settle for a
five drop but any slower than that we
are not going to have a good early game
with bellow on top draw
mill card maddening cacophony so we've
got lots of mill yeah we have a pretty
decent game plan at this moment right I
like it although I shouldn't play this
land my apologies I should be playing
this t land
yes good good
pass Draw Velocut Stone Forge. I think
we can use this as a spell. Try to dig
for more demons and angels. But for now,
we are going to arena. Oh, no, no, no.
Don't play this just yet so people don't
know about it. Play signate first. Yes,
we can play arena next for a surprise.
Yes, they will be very surprised. They
will not see it coming. Okay. On top
with flubs draw. Oh, we drew the Isusa
just in time, actually. Wow. Okay. Oh,
sorry. Let's play our first land. Play
Atusa and play two more lands. Wow,
this is good. Land. Land. Yeah, that's
fine. Um, then we level up sorcerers
class because we have nothing else to
do. Pay one life happens.
The reason I'm not fetching is just
because I want to have more lands in the
deck at this moment. Doesn't matter too
much, but might not matter more than the
one extra life we're paying. So, but
it's it's kind of marginal. We'll see.
On top with bellow artifact, five. Uh,
not the worst one. Not the worst. Not
ideal because I mean, we play this. We
need another artifact, right? Mirror
works. I mean, so let's let's
Yeah, let's thin the deck a little bit.
Again, I talk like it matters. It really
doesn't, but yeah, you want to feel like
you're playing tight, right? So, let's
get a at this point, I think we can get
a shock. Oh, no. We want to get a dolan
for to act activate war room. Yes. Okay,
we got the
to activate war room with cost two life
to activate war room, but it's fine.
Also, we can soak that if we have to.
Probably don't. Untap. Draw.
I like grass tentacles. That's a cool
card, but we're not going to use it just
yet. We're going to ramp. Yeah, we want
to use this with our commander, the
master. So, let's go reach first. Get a
blue and a black search.
Black in play and blue in head.
Okay, draw. Oh, it's a good one, but not
for this turn. So, let's drop our arena
and yeah, let's go for it. So, we exert
the arena.
Yes. And send out Kalia. Who do we
attack? Who's doing well at the moment?
Doesn't seem like I guess flubs is doing
best with a Zusa. Yeah, no one flops.
It's kind of the one of the best cards
in the deck. So, let's punish flops a
little bit with a speed demon. Speed one
connect.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7. I won't bother with
commander damage for Calia. Um hopefully
it won't come back to bite me, but
speed two. And at the end of turn, I
will lose two life and draw two cards.
Angel. Ooh, good. Good. Sarah, Emissary.
Again, not the best one because we we're
not really on the defense right now, but
it's I mean, we can use this to name,
you know, instance, right?
Yeah. Well, we'll see. We'll see. Next
turn, we might just do this. Try to if
if Kalias lives, we'll do do this and
try to get something huge. None of these
will help us snowball, and we want
something like that. So pass flops is
feeling a bit threatened but at the
moment we're still okay. 32 life. Oh
wow. Okay. Okay. So what we do here is
exploration
play. So right now we have four land
drops. We'll play three out of the No,
we'll play two out of the four.
Then we play flubs.
Now we have five land drops with two
used. We'll play our third land out of
five. Draw a card. That correct? That is
correct. Oh, this is now let's play our
fourth land out of five. Draw a card.
Oh, we don't want another land.
Our fifth land out of five. Draw a card.
Oh, we don't want that. Maybe we use the
horizon. Not to put a land into play,
but to draw one more card because we
we'll be kind of stuck anyways next turn
with two cards in hand. So, I might as
well draw the extra card now and try to
find it. Uh, that's just one card
though. Is it worth it? No, I don't
think it's worth it because we're
getting one card and if it's a removal,
sure, but could be anything. And we are
sacrificing the land because the Horizon
also have another mode where I can just
drop this land from hand into play
tapped, which will get us out of this uh
out of the the pickle anyways. Uh, so we
will not do that. We'll crack our two
fetch lands and level up this class.
Um yeah.
So level up
and we need uh we don't have mana. Oh,
we do have mana to level up all the way.
So uh no, we want to save mana for
progress. My apologies. So we used one
land here and then we'll get two more
lands. One tapped and one
untapped.
Got tapped because I paid for the paid
for the level up and level.
There you go. Pass the turn. End of
turn. Double. Well, Waroo was two life.
Draw a card.
Everflow chalice. Not what we need. Draw
one more. Forest.
Oh, slow turns. Slow turns. But mirror
works. Let's get that out there for now.
I don't think this even works with
everflowing chalice does it? No, I don't
think so. Oh well, it can attack. Pass
the master on top. Are we worried about
Kalia? We are. But is there anything we
can do about Kalia? Not really. Like we
can play our commander and try to start
Maybe that's correct. Or do we just
ramp? I think at this point we can
command her into grasp or into cut your
losses just to get something huge from
Kalia to to keep things up. Otherwise,
if we ramp again, we won't have any
threat until two turns after this and it
might be too late. So, I think we I mean
it's very tempting to go greedy with
this, but I think it's correct to to get
our commander out, try to make something
happen, right? So, commander the master
and I will give the rat counters to
myself, I think. Yeah, because the
master can't tap on opponent's turns
just yet. So, ratting ourselves is at
least we can get something we can
potentially use. So, we've got two rat
counters here. Yes. And we pass the turn
on top with Kalia. Doesn't on top.
This is great. Yeah. No one dealt with
Kalia draw. Oh, Jala.
It's very good.
Do we vol stone forge? I mean, do we use
the spell on this or do we just uh drop?
I think we're not exactly short on
cards.
Yeah. So, justella do more damage is
fine. So, let's send our things into
tended to say fluffs again. The master
is scary, but let's divide it a little
bit. Okay, so Kalia
and the demon will go at the master.
Meanwhile, Justella will go at Flops.
Okay, so the I don't think there are any
blockers here. So, we've got do how much
damage is that? 14.
Meanwhile, Flops takes 10. Ouch. Then we
do our signate into black market
connections play.
And also, our speed goes up to three.
Okay, here.
And we draw three cards and lose three
life. Brilliant start one. Oh, we win
next turn. Well, although we probably
shouldn't expect to keep this forward,
but if we do, if we do with full
throttle, we will just finish the game.
This is Kalia pass. Oh, lose three life.
My apologies. But yeah, I will miss a
lot of things. Maybe misplays and even
rules or forgetting triggers. Let me
know. Please, please let me know in the
comments, right? Because um these
mistakes will be common and I'm trying
to get better at this. It's a lot to
keep track of. So, end turn. I will lose
one life to drop this land. But 19 life.
Yeah, we don't have much time.
Fortunately, our resources are built up.
So, as long as we don't get, you know,
five lands in a row, we can definitely
do something this turn with flips.
Maybe even with a leveled up sorcerers
class with a max level one. I mean,
actually, this should be level two.
Okay, draw first land. Let's keep them
separate. Draw. Oh, this is a great
draw.
We want to Yeah, this is great. We can
wipe everything.
Although when we wipe everything, we
will also wipe our board. So let's take
a look. We can do five. We can do five
74.
Do we do three? No. No. I think we can
leave three. Five, seven, four. Do we do
two? I think two is fine to do.
Yeah, let's do five, seven, four, and
two. So one, two, three. Now I have to
pay four more. This is one of the better
answers in this deck. So four more.
Right. No, three more. My apologies.
Three more because we're choosing four
in total. We're choosing two.
Sorry, one second. Do we choose two?
Because if you choose two, we'll end up
with two cards in hand. That will get us
stuck. So maybe not even two. Just Okay.
Like this. We're doing five, four,
seven. Final answer. Final answer. Yes.
Boom.
Oh, Kalia is sad. So is Bellow. There
are no responses. I believe there no
responses. So this gets bounced. Master
gets bounced.
Meanwhile, everything here gets bounced.
Almost everything. Okay. And uh flubs,
we lose nothing. We get to draw a card.
Chaos warp. Which one do we warp? Let's
warp the We can tap these two to pay for
the cost.
Uh let's warp one, two, three. Do we
warp the arena or the black market
connections? I think the arena because
haste is huge. Like we are we're at 19
life, right? And clearly we are winning
at this point. So let's warp the uh
although with Kalia is a bit risky, but
I think we do it. So let's warp the
arena of
glory. Chaos warp. And we draw a card.
This is a creature removal, but it's
also a land. So we'll play this later.
Chaos warp happens. Shuffle this away.
Away.
Cut myself
flip announcing reasonable
not the worst outcome. And we'll play
this land. I guess tapped just because
life is kind of short now. So this is
our second land.
Third land.
Top is brilliant.
Okay.
Rapid hybridization. There's no target
though.
Is this where we top? I should have
taught early. Probably should have
taught or
or maybe we level up the sorcerers class
and hold this rapid hybridization in
case anything happens and we can win the
turn after.
I think that's a good plan. That's a
good plan because we're otherwise we
have to kind of go nuts with the land
with the top. Try to dig more spells and
there are not enough targets on the
board at this point and we play three
lands this turn. So it's not not bad. So
let's do that. One, two, three, four,
five. Five. Uh we're paying two. two
life for this. Not this, sorry. For
leveling up our sorcerers class. If this
sticks, then we pretty we're pretty
likely to win next turn. And we pass the
turn. Bellow on top.
Draw.
N. Yeah, Bellow's not doing much. We
really want to interact with something,
but it's difficult. So, let's get an
Echos of Eternity. We can only hope that
our late game is better. Or did I play
the wrong land? Colorless. Oh, we need
to play a different land. My apologies.
Castic warfront. Yes. So, we can make
three colorless, three diamond. Let's do
that.
Pass the turn. Untap. Draw. We know we
have a problem with flubs. But can we do
anything about it? We can mill. We can
mill and try to steal something. We can
bounce some. Can this bounce? Oh, this
can bounce the sorcerers class. Okay,
we're holding this up then. Okay, so
this is our plan. Our plan is to Alvara
Aara.
If we don't need to, we'll factor
fiction. Not the again, not the best
play, but can we afford to play our
commander and hold on? Commander cost
four. This will cost three. No, not
enough.
Okay, we are going to just we play the
land. We'll just pass. Okay, Kalia, we
untap with black market connections. I
think we pay everything, do we? Yeah, we
want to board. We want to board. So,
actually, do we need card draw? Maybe
not because we're probably playing this,
are we? Or
let's just draw. 1 2 3 4 5 six. We do
have life. So, I don't have a changeling
token. This will do. Um, whatever this
is. And treasure. Now, we draw two,
which are two lands. This works really
well with Amaria Sheper, but we don't
have a graveyard right now. Do we drop
our Jazella out there? No, I don't think
so. We We are also dying to flops at
this point. There's there are no
artifacts on the board for us to use our
Cavern Horde Dragon. So, do we Calia or
do we do we speed demon again? Tempted
to say speed demon just to draw more is
with Oh, maybe farewell. Actually,
sorry, I forgot about farewell. I think
this is the time to farewell.
Yeah, graveyards, enchantments,
creatures.
Oh,
okay. Small misplay. Shouldn't have made
this, but pretty sure it's correct to
farewell.
So, let's do that.
Let's do enchantments.
Graveyards.
Do we do great? Yes, we do. And
creatures
wipe everything. Any responses? Doesn't
seem like there will be any responses
from anyone. Exile.
Uh, yes. Graveyard Flops is pretty sad
about this. Yeah, but there's not much
we can do. Exile. Exile. Command zone.
Exile.
Exile. Exile.
Commander attacks.
Uh, should be one, right? One extra.
Bellow. Just can't stick anything. Yeah,
the master is very happy about this. And
that's our turn. We'll have to discard.
Let's keep winding canyons.
Uh oh. Let's exile the graveyards first
before we forget.
Yep. Okay, now we discard. I think maybe
we want to keep this in a marsh flats
just to Yeah, just to get value. So,
next turn we can we can justella or cow
horde dragon.
Yeah. So, we discard. Let's discard the
dragon
and maybe Sarah's Emissary cuz that's
kind of, you know, you can do some
instant speed tricks with that. And one,
two, three, four, five, six, seven. So,
we need to discard one more. Yeah,
winding cannons can go for for for now.
We don't want to keep two lands,
especially when there's also a Velica
Stone Forge. I think that's reasonable.
Pass. All right, flops. We untap with a
rapid hybridization in hand. There are
no targets though, so it's a bit tricky.
Unhapp draw. Hall breach does have
targets.
So the play is this is tricky. This is
tricky. Um
I think we flip top. That's what we do.
And then we play flubs. Then we can
continue the chain. Then we discard the
rapid right to uh to breach. That's the
plan. Okay. So we s top just to see.
Maybe should have done it before, but
same top. Okay, got Oh, Yuru. Yur is not
bad. Yuth and gutter snipe. So, we want
Yuruth, I think.
Yeah. Okay, let's do that. Let's do
that. So, a flip top into.
And then we play flops.
One, two, three, four, five.
So, this will set us up pretty well for
next turn, I'd say.
Then we
roof
uh have to pay a life and we discard rap
hybrid hybridization and we hall breach
to blow up
just one artifact. So, let's do the
metal rock for Kalia.
Okay, this happens. And now we get to
draw. We get to exile the top two cards.
Then we can play those cards. So we
exile the top two cards here. And we'll
play a top. Yes. Play a top. Then we
exile. Oh, we pay mana for the top. And
we exile two more cards.
Fortunately, no land. We do need some
lands here. So, let's pay one life to
blow up uh vendor blast the other man
rock for Kalia cuz Kalia is definitely
scary.
Okay, then we draw two more. Yes.
Yeah, we might not get the gutter snip
this turn. Oh, we might. We might. Uh,
let's play a breeding pool untapped. Oh,
life is life is getting low. Two
moreonic
rift. Might have to waste that. play our
uh second land for the turn. Get two
more.
Yeah, I think we drop gutter snipe and
pass the turn. Yeah, is that correct?
Yeah, let's drop gutter snipe.
Pay two life. Exile top two cards. None
of these are relevant. So, everything
else is exiled.
Yeah, there's no board. So, we just set
up what we can. Play our two lands a
turn and hope for the best.
Pass bellow.
Let's keep trying. Bellowh land. Okay,
almost do again. That's good. So, we
mirror works. One, two, three, four,
five. And play overflowing chalice.
Sure.
Or we do it the other way around.
Chalice. It doesn't matter too much. We
don't have much to do. Oh, actually, we
do. We do. Cuz if we can hold two mana,
we can cycle the shelter thicket. So,
let's play that better. Let's play a
chalice with one counter. Then, we tap
it. One, two, three, four. Do I? No,
like this, right? Tap it for Hold up.
Chalice. Oh, the math was off. So, we
still get just to get to keep one mana.
Um, yeah, we pass with one mana up. Now,
at the end of turn, this is what we've
been waiting for. Let's fact or fiction
targeting. Might as well target. Doesn't
matter. It'll be me. It will be me to
split. So, we've got cultivate. got
reenact the crime a land and ramp.
Honestly, I'm tempted to just do this,
you know, ramp and gas. And this card is
actually very good when combined with
any mill, but is that giving them too
much? No, I think it's fine. I think
it's fine. And uh for the master, which
one do I pick? I think I'll pick It's
tempting to just take this, but then
that's like saying good split. You never
want to approve of their split. Make
them feel good about themselves. even
though it's just me.
So, uh let's
at least we can cycle, right? Let's take
this. So, then we can cycle into
something good, right? So, yeah, to
prove ourselves, right? So, cycle
migration path. Draw a card. See, see
what I was saying. So, pull pro. Uh
there's no there is a graveyard. There
is a graveyard.
Maybe we are on to something on top.
H. So we draw first and the consumer
aberration. Wow. Okay. Then we mill two
from rad. We got a land at a nonland. So
we lose one rat, lose one life. All
right. We are a bit short on mana. And
with this board, I do think we have some
time. We don't really have to answer
anything anymore. Gutter knight is
strong, but it's not like I don't think
it's going to kill us this turn, right?
We have to do something.
What's the something we do, though? Do
we primordial? Well, we primordial.
There's only what's in Cali's grave,
which is not that much. Maybe we do.
Maybe we do. But I think this game is
kind of nearing its end, even though
like totals are not the lowest. So,
let's let's put some threat onto the
board. Yeah. And play our land. I think
I think that's So, let's drop the
primordial.
One, two, three, four.
Five, six, seven. Let's bring up from
Cali's grave.
Calvin Horde
Dragon. Is that correct? Or do we take
Sarah's emissary?
I think Sarah's Emissary and give
ourselves protection from creatures so
that we can't be touched by Gutter
Snipe. Yeah, we're 25 lives. Yeah. So,
we are kind of protected while Fluffs
guns everything else down. Does Fluffs
have anything in the graveyard? No
creature. Although
this is kind of susceptible to removal,
but I think protection from creatures
also gives us protection from Kalia and
from Bellow. So, it's not the worst
play. We also kind of have some threats
on the board rather than just doing
nothing. Yeah, our mill plan is not
working well right now. And we're
supposed to mill and then I mean to be
fair, we we did bring something back.
But yeah, let's do this pass. Kya on
top.
Okay, this our plan didn't go well
because yeah, we clearly was hoping to
do this, but now we don't have the mana
thanks to flubs. I think we just play
our land, play Kalia, and pass. Where's
our Calia? It's in our hand. It's in our
hand. Oh, did I forget to discard for I
did. So, let's Sorry. Go to discard for
um for the master. So, let's discard Ram
spell land
and two lands.
Sure. And we are at seven cards.
Okay, now Kalia.
So we Calia and
pass.
What else can we do? It's not much.
Calia and we play the Valakut Stone
Forge.
Yeah. And pass the turn.
Unfortunate, but that's what we can do.
So next turn at least we can drop this
with Kalia hopefully.
Okay, fluffs untapped with everything.
This will be a good turn especially if
we can deal with the Amaria shepherd.
Let's see. Draw for turn. Oh, actually
instead of drawing, we would exile these
two. This is great because we can copy
the gutter snipe. There's no point
playing abundance because we have a
roof. So let's drop the uh let's play
this as another gutter snipe.
And abundance is in exile. Let's keep
our pile here. Uh, just keep it here, I
guess. Oops. O.
All right. So, we played this. Pay three
mana. Exile. Two more. Okay. We got the
creature removal.
Let's play a land first. First land of
the turn. Draw. Exile top two.
Uh, second land of the turn. Exile top
two.
All right, let's do it. So,
Cyberman conversion. We're going to
convert the AIA shepherd.
Not shepherd. What's it called? Sarah's
emissary. Boom.
Yep. This happens unfortunately. And uh
it will deal four damage.
Sorry, not master, but everyone else.
But starting now, the master will be
taking damage. And what can we do damage
with? We can do it with
Let's flip top to see if we have better
options. Flip top. Exile 2 into the
royal is nice. So we do that into the
royal.
Let's bounce the bounce the Calia I
guess. Yeah. Everyone take four.
Kalia goes back to hand.
Meanwhile, we exile two more cards. One
of them is top. Let's play the top.
And I think we continue to top. Or do we
pay three to bounce? Uh, I think top is
better. Yeah, it's digging us deeper and
it's uh cheaper usually. So, let's flip
top again. All the top two cards. None
of these are good. So, then we can play
the bounce spell. Okay. One, two, three.
Let's bounce the the marrow works uh
graveyard. Yes, Mars back to hand.
Everyone take four.
We are at nine life. So we have to be
careful like we might have to deal with
the primordial next so that we don't
take combat damage.
Um
yeah. So then we exile two more. Yes.
One of them is top. Let's play the top
and we will play struggle. Struggle will
target the primordial dealing more than
10 damage to it. Struggle happens.
Uh okay. First, let's do it in the right
order for once. Two cards and trigger
primordial dice. Whoops.
And uh we got three more mana. And
there's no target. There is target for
reality shift.
Do we use it? I think we have to because
we don't get to keep it. So, let's
reality shift
the the token or the the flipped the
flipped um Sarah's adversary. So, this
one gets exiled.
Uh but first, we have to do the damage.
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 And we exile the
top two cards. Okay, this is something
we can actually Oh, this is not deeming
failure. I was going to say we can cast
it, but no, we haven't drawn any cards
this turn. So it looks like all these
will be ex exiled.
There's nothing we can cast from here.
There is nothing we can cast from here.
Okay, I think we passed the turn and uh
yeah, we will win next turn if they
don't do anything this point. Bellow is
thinking about taking itself apart.
Yeah.
Uh what are we doing with Okay, let's
play a land.
Make some tokens. Mirror works. Ugan.
Yeah, maybe just Ugan. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
mana. Let's keep one up for Ugan. Is
that eight? Let's make sure. 1 2 3 4 5 6
7. Yes, Ugan. Ugan is going to minus
three. Yeah, minus three. So that we
don't get gutter snipe anymore. Yeah. So
it's at four.
And any responses from anyone? No, it
doesn't seem like it. So everything is
gone from Flips forward. Now flips costs
seven mana. It's been casted twice.
Okay, finally we did something. Pass.
The master untaps draw and mill one for
the red counter. And now Rat is gone. We
lose one life. We're at eight life.
Whoops. Yeah, that last turn wasn't too
clever. And now we I don't think we have
a window to ramp, do we? I think we cast
the master and hope to hope to cut our
losses and get something to save us.
Yeah, there's nothing we can get now
from Calia's grave. We might
or we grasp for something from from
Bellow. Yeah, I think we do need to cut
cut m cast master because we have
nothing else that can steal from
graveyards in our hand, which is
unfortunate. So, we cast the master for
four.
Let's first grasp. So, maybe we can get
a mana rockers. Eh, yeah, let's grasp
first and see. So, grasp
against bellow hopefully. I don't even
know what we're hoping for, but
something to gain life with. Yeah,
Bellow is the deck with artifacts. So,
let's mill Billow for eight.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 7 8 Oh, the party tree.
Holy.
Oh, this is close. Do we get the chim or
the party tree? Party tree gains life,
but chiml is value. Let's think about
that. Party tree, we can master. We can
cast master.
We do get the mana is helpful, but
getting free spells is also nice. Now, I
think we're at a point where the party
tree won't save us,
but something random might. Yeah, I'm
tempted to go for Chim just for a little
bit more spice cuz with our hand right
now, we are not doing anything till next
turn. And that's spanking on the master
sticking. If the master gets removed
again by, you know, you mean there's an
Ugan, there's flubs, we're done. But
this can be anything, right? and also
uncounterable, right? Because all the
counters lost this game. So, let's do
that chim.
And uh at the beginning of my end step,
I will go to combat. Go to Wait, do we
cast or do we just bank on the chim? I
don't think we should. I think we should
cast the master anyways. I was thinking
about holding the vara, but we should be
a bit more proactive now with this
board. So, yeah, let's do the master.
And we r this time. We rad. I don't
think we ride ourselves anymore. That's
rad. Who? Kalia. Sure. Kalia's dying
soon though. Yeah, let's rad Calia. Why
not? And now Chim for the miracle
discover five. H
conduit of worlds. Not good right now,
but next turn we can do something.
Maybe.
Right. Let's pass our turn. Kalia sad on
top with our three speed draw. And then
we rat two moat
and ruin his ultimatum. Minus two. No
more rad.
Now what? We can't speed demon. We're at
six life. We can play land. We can play
kalion. Two, three, four, five, six. We
have to play something and then lifelink
with it basically is the blind. But we
only have six mana. So we can't marry a
shepherd. Not even close. We can
With this hand, I think it's just
Kalias, but Kalia is probably going to
get if it doesn't get fluffs, it's going
to get Ugan. But there is no other
choice. I mean, speed, we'll go to three
and Ugan can kill us. So, probably not
that.
But then we probably die anyways at six
life. At least the speed demon can link
some life the turn after. So can Kalia.
Yeah, let's let's do Kalia. Have to go
big. Two, three, four. Calia and uh
yeah, let's play the land. We're not
getting the Aaria Shepard greed. So then
we pass the turn. Okay, we untap with
Flubs uh with nine life and lots of
land. So let's draw our card. Although
flubs does cost seven, which is
difficult.
Draw a card. Dryad. Let's play flubs.
Three, four, five, six. Dryad is very
helpful because uh of all the life
payment lands we have. Dryad can negate
all that. We no longer have to pay life
into lands. Dryad sorry, flubs for seven
mana.
Dryad for three mana.
Um yeah, like this. And before we draw,
I think we top to hopefully get some
lands.
Let's see what we can get.
Yeah, let's top.
Solid. Doesn't win us the game, but can
help a little bit. Um, sure. Oh, whoops.
Yeah, let's do this this order.
Cabin of the dead. So, draw. This will
be our second land. Uh, field of the
dead, right? When it enters, we make a
zombie on top. Okay. Draw. Play another
land. That's our third land. Our final
land, which makes another zombie. and
draw sword tooth.
Pay three for the swart tooth. So, we
got uh we draw a card first, but we have
city's blessing. Yay. And uh we drew the
mystical tutor. How can that help us?
How can that help us? I guess we tutor
for removal. Okay, let's search for
something.
So, we've played we have one more land
draw. Let's do this. So, first we draw.
Oh, we found a removal. Uh,
there's also Ugan, which can minus
again. Yeah, we couldn't find another
damage source, which is unfortunate, but
let's see what we have in the deck.
Ether Flux is good. Oh, can't search for
that.
Okay, let's get Snap because we are
short on mana. So, we can uh kind of
cast one more spell after that. So,
shuffle. This is on top. And we wild
magic surge. We're going to surge the
um Ugan. Yes, sir. Ugan automatic surge.
Ugan destroyed. Uh but we give him
another permanent another planes walker
which probably is K or Ugan. Oh, we know
that it's Ugan. Yeah, because there's no
K in there. Although Ugan can't really
wipe. It can kill fluffs. But yeah, I
mean there is a weaker Ugan in there.
So, okay, let's do let's try it. Let's
try it because we can't leave this Ugan
on the field. So, destroy and flip until
we get So, let's do this fast.
Oh, they got the good Ugan.
And that comes with
seven loyalty counters. We We might have
messed up there. Um, we'll see. Snap.
Snap the
the master or the Kalia. I think it's
still the Kalia. The master can't kill
us immediately. Kalia can't. So, let's
snap the Kalia. Draw a card. Kalia goes
back to hand. Come on. Two lands.
Let's play a land. This our third land
of the turn actually. Is it? I think so.
Yeah. Third land of the turn.
Uh, draw a card. Make a zombie.
Okay, we are a bit stuck. Let's sense
it. Let's spin senses top. One, two,
three. Yeah, this. Oh, pick your poison.
Do we use it now? I don't think so. I
mean, we can make uh we can do artifact.
Doesn't do much. We can Yeah, I think we
hold up resculpt. That's the correct
play. We hold up resculpt. So, we keep
this on top and hope for the best. I
mean, we have city's blessing. What can
go wrong? What can go wrong? Okay, pass
the turn. On top with Ugan. Thank you,
Flops, for the gift. We might actually
be able to do something on top. Draw.
So we add mana, play something, play
another thing, and play bellow. How much
mana do we have? We have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 mana. We are one short, but
we haven't played a land yet. So we have
exactly uh No, we don't.
Mirror works banner.
I think we should be playing Bellow at
this point. Or do we just set up for
next turn and hold up air with Karat?
We're at 17 life.
So if again let's make sure we have so 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 mana.
So we can cast these two and copy it.
But but then we are we don't have
protection. So maybe we just play both
and keep protection up. Yeah, I think
that's the correct play. Do we need to
deal with this side? We we can't cuz
we're Yeah, we're isoling things. Okay.
Okay, we're fine. We're fine. So add
mana plus zero and uh keep these two and
tap all these out. That would be 10
mana. We play uh Mirror Works and a
Kinchin. Uh first of all, Mirror Works
will trigger Ugan on this board. I'm
thinking it's Flubs. Yeah, I think it's
Flubs. So, let's do that.
Flubs is now casting nine mana.
Yeah.
And with our next spell, we will exile
the master, right? Or is it the conduit?
Let's see what they have in the
graveyard. The primordial, I believe. G
Primordial. Primordial can get something
from Kalia which is annoying but oh yeah
I think we might have to do the conduit.
Do we kill the master or the conduit?
I'm leaning towards the conduit. Uh
sorry the master. The master because
primordial I mean they can get the
dragon from Kali. Let's see. They can
get the Yeah, the dragon. That's it
right. And the dragon sure it hits Ugan
or hits us. They make some treasures.
It's not terrifying. But with the master
they can mill something and we don't
know what they can mill from Kalia for
example. And yeah so I think we deal
with the master. So, let's exile the
master goes to the command zone
and
oh, I mean with our banner, sorry, we
cast the banner as on the master and we
choose elementals and we've passed the
turn on top
draw.
Looks like we don't have a lot of choice
here. We got all these mail cards. Alt
of dementia, consuming aberation. Oh,
consuming aberration with altar of
dementia. That is a thing. The
graveyards are not huge though, so I
don't think we're killing anyone with a
mill except for maybe flips. Um, do we
uh do we primordial into dragon? I think
we do cuz the dragon can hit. So, we're
at 1, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight mana. Yeah, I think the
last line is Oh, we can't cast any more
spells after that, right?
Uh, there's only one. Oh, so then we
can't even chim. Oh, no. The conduit
doesn't work well. But instead, maybe we
don't. Did we play this land this turn?
I don't remember. Oh well. Uh so eight
mana
consuming aberration into alternia.
And we can just threat to kill someone.
Yeah. Okay. Consuming aberration.
Alternia. And when we do that, everyone
mills until they get a land, including
not including ourselves, every opponent.
So Kalia mill. No, we got the land.
plus mill.
We got four and uh bellow mill.
Oops.
Yep. Five cards. Okay. Okay. Now we
trigger the chimu. Chim chim chim.
Nope. Discover five, right? Five. Yes.
Ah, wrap. Okay. Okay, happens. The rest
go on the bottom, I'm guessing. And uh
before we do that, everyone mills again.
A mill. That's not a land.
Three cards. Flops mill.
Not a land. That's a land. Three cards.
And bellow. One, two,
four cards. Stomping ground. And we
search for a land.
this so we can hold up cycling fracture
sanity doesn't do much but something
it's something we might have to do it
and uh that's our turn so at actually at
this point we can use altar to kill
anyone
I'm tempted to do it to it won't be oh
actually we have a really good board yes
this was all part of the plan but um
because what happens is Kalia probably
can't kill
But flubs can. But the problems is flubs
needs to draw cards to keep the chain
going. And we can just in response to
any draw and mill the deck. And if flubs
doesn't do anything, we can just mill
bellow. Do we have enough? I think we
might. Uh we we have to count. Let's do
a quick count.
Okay, we're back from the count. There
are 44 cards among all our opponent's
graveyards and there are 65 cards in
Bellow's deck.
So, if we use the fractured sanity, we
can go up to um 44 + 12, right? We can
go to 56, which is about 10 cards short.
So, no, we cannot kill Bellow.
But but if you know no one does
anything, we can mill we can mill bellow
down to 10 cards and after that after
that they're dead, right? They're close
to dead at least from the fractured
sanity.
So we have a plan. We have a plan. All
right, let's pass the turn. Kalia
untaps. Let's uh crack this fetch might
as well. Or not yet. Not yet. Maybe we
still have a chance of shepherd. We can,
you know, have a soaring top deck.
Saring
close.
This is where we cry a little bit.
Hoarding brood lord tutor for something.
Not enough mana. Speed demon. We have
six life. Jala. Jella.
Oh boy. Boy. I think maybe just to, you
know, in case flubs has those one damage
pingers and we can just not take damage.
Yeah, it's not looking good for us. Um,
is there a way to, you know, try to play
to win rather than not lose? I think,
honestly, just sella plus full throttle
if it lives is the plan. We can kill two
people.
Yeah, I might as well try it. So, we
have to crack our fetch
and uh use our treasure and just sell
out. Yeah, there's honestly not much
else we can do here. So, let's get a
land.
Pass the turn. flops. We should be
winning here.
But but yeah, it's scary the consuming
operation. We do see the threat of
consuming operation. So we flops
untapped, right? And we are going to
draw. But actually, does the master the
master has to think, do we allow flops
to draw here? Because flops does have
here you see um eight damage on board. I
mean with this uh yeah so eight master
the master will die if flops attacks. So
also Flubs does have this card in the
graveyard survive which shuffles all
graveyards into library. But the problem
is if we kill Flubs, if the master kills
Flubs,
it just dies to Bellow, right? So we
have a kind of a standoff situation
here. So what we are hoping for is for
Flubs to do things and uh deal with at
least the Ugan, maybe an artifact. And
we are willing to lose our stuff even if
that means Yeah, because we are
guaranteed to lose if we kill Flubs
right now. So we just don't do anything.
Yeah, I don't think I don't think the
master will respond to anything flips
does right now. Now that we re
re-evaluate the situation right now,
Bellows is the problem. Yeah, unless
Phubs is kind of pinging us to death,
we're not going to kill Flops.
Fwell on top and draw a beast within.
And
we have two cards in hand. So what we
will do is I don't think we even use the
beast within do we? Yeah. Let's just um
do the storm. Uh maybe we want the
beast. No storm clan artist.
One, two, three, four. Oh, also I forgot
again that flops is not on the field. So
can we afford to play flips? One, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine. I think we have to. I mean, this
is a flop deck, right? We We What are we
going to do? Let's see what's in
graveyard that we can do. There's
nothing. There is nothing.
We can zombie people, but yeah, that's
not going to kill. We can kill Ugan.
Okay, I think we combat into Ugan first.
So, let's attack with our sword to this
because it's not blocking. Seven damage
to Ugan
and these can block. Yes, we're going to
dice.
Then
we're going to cast flubs. One, two,
three, four, five, six, seven. Sorry.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine. Holy crap, it's expensive.
Flubs.
Okay, then we beast within something.
Do we try? I guess we can't really touch
the master cuz we will literally die if
we do. So, we beast within the Jella.
Yeah, let's beast within the Jella
because we have more artifact removal
than creature removals. So, let's piece
within the Jella.
Uh, so what we do is we draw a card and
we Sorry, this treasure shouldn't be
there. Let's create a treasure token.
Uh, we draw a land. The cell is gone.
It's replaced by a beast token. And we
play a land. Our first land of the turn.
Draw a card.
Make a zombie.
We drew another land. But this is also a
removal. What do we remove? Nothing.
Let's play our second land. Draw a card.
Make a zombie. Now we drew a ballad get
sanctuary. That is interesting. We can
definitely play it. But um where do we
what do we get? Let's see. We have to
deal with
we have to deal with see but the thing
is we can't really
deal with bellow too much. If we do then
we become the only threat
and uh yeah we'll die to the master. So
let's see beast within
exploration pick your poison.
Is there something that can allow us to
respond to things? Cyberman conversion.
Vendle blast. Maybe we overload
Venoblast.
Do we have enough mana? One, two. Sorry,
this is not on two. One, two, three,
four. One, two, three. We do have enough
mana to overload vendast.
Uh, if we do that, will the master allow
us? I think they will. I think they will
because again, we are dead anyways. Like
we're at the mercy of the master. But if
we overand blast. Yeah. Again, we know
that if the master mills us, they will
die to Bellow. So, let's do that. Okay.
Valad san Sanctuary. And we get one more
treasure for casting. And we draw a card
for casting.
We find a cursed idol.
We drew this. But we're going to target
Meadow Blast. We didn't pay the mana. My
apologies. We pay the mana for the
balag. And we blasted
Metal Blast.
Discarding you find a curse title. Now
let's see responses. Bellow
has a response called heroic
intervention.
So we are going to do just that. Yeah,
bellow shines for once. Meanwhile, the
master we're losing our our entire board
except for consuming operation. Are we
going to allow that? At this point,
Flubs is kind of winning.
But again, Bellow just kept its board.
So I don't think we kill flops even
though ah it's really tempting.
Yeah, I think we have to just let it
happen and keep the keep the aberration.
Okay, so this happens for the last turn.
J goes in here. Everything else goes in
graveyard. Meanwhile, Kalia doesn't
care. What can Kalia do? Think our
time's over for Kalia. And u yeah,
that's the turn for flops. Now Bellow on
taps. This is going to be hopefully a
decent turn for us. Oops. On top drawu
is useful.
I think we cycle this just to hope to
get Hold on. Are these elementals? Nope.
They're spirits. So, we cycle our shter
thicket. Or do we just ah wait, hold on.
Maybe we just attack. Maybe we just
attack. Who do we attack into? We attack
into Kalia.
Kalia has to block. We can kill Calia.
Or we can try to kill master.
But then there's flubs. If we kill
master, what are we going to do about
flubs? It's a tricky situation here. So
flubs is winning now. There's no win on
board for flubs, right? But is not doing
anything. And master can do something.
So we try to kill master.
Uh
we need to draw some cards, too. We're
at 17 life. If we fail to kill master,
it's over
kind of. Yeah, let's let's hope to drop
something else.
Let's see if we cycle into a four mana
artifact. We drop it. We copy it. We
don't have No, no, no, no. Let's just
drop our bellow. Okay, bellow.
A one, two, hold on. One, two, three for
bellow.
Then we attack. We attack for four and
four. Yes.
And we're attacking into
Calia. We're killing Calia. Not sure
that's a good idea. We need to draw two
cards. That's the thing. And we're not
getting through flops or I mean the
master we can get through with one.
Okay, let's let's kill Calia. Let's kill
Cal. We want to draw two cards. It will
cost us another three mana leaving us
with four more. But yeah. Yeah, we need
to develop our board otherwise we just
can't win. So, we need to we need to
make something happen. Uh, one, two,
three to give
this trample or sorry, we can't do that
just yet. We have to attack first.
Attack Kalia. Kalia blocks one of them
with a beast and we give the blocked
artifact trample. This will deal five
damage to Kalia. So, that's game over
for Kalia. believe
it is. Yeah, to be fair, the game was
long over for Cali. Just couldn't
recover despite his efforts. So, we're
going to draw two cards. We drew a board
wipe and a land. Not what we want. Uh we
we'll play the land. We will cycle
shelter thicket just in case we get
something.
Let's cycle it because we can still use.
Oh, hold up. Hold up. Never mind. Never
mind. We don't cycle because we also
have so can then which can make
blockers. That's very important, right?
So
yeah, because with four mana we can use
both which is you know it's it's a
response. It's a okay let's do that
instead. Pass. Now the master at the end
of turn we're going to cycle the
fractured sanity.
Cycle draw a card. Each opponent mills
four.
Flops knows four.
We on top draw
island. Play the island.
This is tough. This is tough. We don't
have any answers. Do we have anything in
grave? I don't believe so. All we have
is a consuming aberration and eight
life.
So, and also our armory of our Calalia
is gone. We no longer can reanimate
something big. I mean, these two are
useless when it comes to graveyards. So,
we have to go with a mill plan. Yeah, I
think we can mill them out. Or do we cut
our losses twice?
Casualty, too. We don't have casualty.
Okay, I think our best bet here is to
mail half the library for a bellow and
then cast two more spells. Use imagining
cacophony and then tangle thrren to
hopefully mill them both out. That is
our one chance because on board we have
nothing. So let's do that. Cut your
losses targeting bellow.
One, two, three, four, five, six. One,
two, three. So until we get a land. Now
we are kind of regretting not using the
graveyard shuffle card. We thought the
board was a bigger threat, but it was
because of what the master had. But
maybe the master would have allowed us
to shuffle. H maybe not. It's hard to
It's hard to tell. Okay, so we mil a
bunch and hello. We mill this is to the
consumer operation. Okay, we mill. And
now we count our library and mill half.
Okay, so it turns out there are 58
cards. So we mill 29. And now the
master, we are going to cast a cut your
losses. Sorry, the other card. We're
going to cast a maddening cacophony.
Everyone mills
eight. Each opponent mills eight. But
first we mill until we get a land.
Whoops.
Okay. Yeah, I think it's over for flubs
and
bellow and bellow mills eight. Sorry.
Mills till we get a land. Oh, that's a
land. Did I? Okay. Till we get a land.
And then we mill eight.
Is there anything we can do? I don't
think so. We are milled to death. Flubs.
Yeah, there's nothing we can do from the
graveyard. We We will see. We will see,
but probably not. Meanwhile,
Milo will mill until it gets a land.
Sorry. Mil uh mill eight. I mean,
not quite. Not quite. Um so then the
master casts one more spell in Tangle
Fledron. Also a blocker. No, it's not
over. So, Bellow, we will mill until we
get a land. One, two. Okay, so how many
cards left? So, Bellow has 14 cards left
and one turn to kill the master. Now, as
the master, do we attack Bellow? If we
attack, it's going to have to block with
Bellow, but then it can just recast
and we lose a blocker. They pay five for
Bellow and then attack us with No. So we
are betting on that they don't have a
another big artifact in hand which I
think is not unsafe to bet. I mean they
didn't cast anything right. So
yeah I think we go for it. I think we go
for it. Okay so consuming operation
attacks bellow and bellow has been
waiting for this moment. It's going to
soen discard it with channel using three
mana like this and create two colorless
spirit tokens. Here you go. And we are
going to block with one of them. The
master is very sad about this. Now sure
one spirit dice and do we also use su
for something?
I don't think yeah I don't think there's
any point. So yeah, combat is finished.
The master is not dead just yet because
we have one blocker against two. Uh,
actually, no, we're dead. We're dead.
Whoops. Okay. Okay. Well, let's see what
flops can do. Probably not much on tap.
Flubs
draws and dice. Okay, flops is dead and
all that's left is city's blessing and
speed on Kalia's side. Uh yeah, we are
very happy to untap.
And let's draw a card from our deck is a
Nautiloid ship.
Yeah, let's play it. Let's play it and
let's go in
and extend the head. Good game. Good
game. Good games.
Good games.
Finally,
Bellow comes out with a victory somehow
after doing nothing.
So, you see how well I'm simulating your
average pod. The deck that did nothing
ends up taking over the game. Flops
could have played better with the
creatures, especially with the Jella on
board. I think we were just too scared
of Calia there. But today, rather than
analyzing the game, I want to focus more
a bit on the video format itself. I'm
looking to make this into a series
potentially, but there are some kinks I
need to work out. And this is where you
come in. If you've stuck around till
now, clearly there's something you like
here, and I love your suggestions. Let's
do a giveaway. And yeah, let's do a
giveaway. And again, I'm only promoting
it here, nowhere else. Just leave a
comment. How can I improve this series?
What are some advantages you find
compared to other gameplay series? And
are there any major problems I should
address? Let's see. I'll pick a comment
or two and give away let's say $50. I
guess I I again I want to find a better
way to do giveaways, but for now it's
the best I can do cuz PayPal, everyone
has PayPal almost and yeah, let's do
that. So from my perspective, this
series is interesting to make because we
can share more of the decision-m whether
is right or wrong and our thought
thought process, right? and choosing
which cards to play and threat
assessment and all that. I'm also
playing with nearperfect knowledge of
the decks. While I also do know all the
cards in hand, but I find that I'm still
able to simulate how I would play
without that knowledge. It's not
perfect, but close enough to how you
play in a normal game with friends. And
I also enjoy not having any politics
involved. It's all just the game itself.
But yeah, that's all for today. Thank
you for staying till the end.